my
yes young yoon i am so excited to talk
to you you are outstanding in everything
you do but especially in the show i
first wanted to ask you about the
opening credits scene because i love how
the cast is dancing in the pacheco
parlor
how was that for you was that fun for
you and what did you have to do for that
mo my age we don't dance in korean way
you know the 74 years is
not familiar with the dancing especially
me i'm not good dancer and then sue hugh
asked me to do the dancing so i was
my face was like this out
no i can't i don't want to dance why
do i have to i'm the grandmother why do
i have to dance and then she insists and
then yes like you i after to see that
credit and yes i loved that
music and dancing was very
oh it's going to be so that that was yes
you should always listen to showrunner
well you're good in it was it fun for
you while you were doing it when you
finally said it i was embarrassed the
front of music and then we were dancing
and the young kids like solomon and
having fun young young ones but
me um
how would i dance i was really
embarrassed
well i love your dancing i'm so happy
you did it and i'm so excited for
american audiences to see you starring
in an american tv series because i know
you've been in other shows like since
eight but this is like your starring
role in an american tv series so i
wanted to know what about this project
were you like i want to do it like did
you read something in the script or you
were like yes yes
first i read the script but
to me i had
it's not proud of saying long
experience but i happened to be i had a
long experience the actor from korea i
had career like 56 years or more than
that so anyway but so to all the role as
same to me
rules at all to me but
this one after i read the script somehow
just i had
immediate connection to sanja
and i had to play this role so
i
went out
and get the novel
by minding me and then it gives me more
desire to play this role how
strength and how determination to
survive
that is uh it's like me or somehow so
that's why
yeah
what did what about sanja where did that
you really connected to i know you said
her strength but there was there
something in your life that you were
like wow i really have to play this
no it's not that i think not only that
her honesty back in those times
actually she
pregnant with
not been married
but back in those times it's sinful
things you know
uh
the girl pregnant
not being married so she but she was
very honest about what happened to her
and but she happened to meet the nice
pastor who knows she's pregnant and then
she followed him to go to overseas you
know going japan and then
without speak any language
and
she had to survive from there
not speaking in
not english the japanese and then it was
kind of
that i can feel i was here in
back in 74 till 82 and back in my time i
couldn't speak
but speak a little bit of english but
not a word not i was worse than this
time i think
at the time so it reminds of me
trying to survive in this country not
speaking
english and
other than that
somehow i can feel that korean woman i i
think any woman would be like that if
you have a
children then you have some very amazing
strengths somehow
coming from somewhere
trying to protect my son
and
she could do anything for their son so i
don't know it's just from i think any
human being has that
yeah nature i think
yeah especially women that was so
beautifully said and
yeah john you have so much insight and
what i was thinking about watching this
show is this show the time that it spans
is from the early 20th century to the
late 1980s so i wanted to ask you how is
korea changed in that time frame
well i cannot remember that that time
because my mother's time but me i can
see the change of um still i'm i'm 74 75
i'm not sure i cannot even count my age
i live too long anyway
yes i can see the change of career
because
uh
nowadays
differences
when we were my time like i was 20
something then you cannot go travel with
the boyfriend that's very
very unless you're married
that never happened in my time but
nowadays they always say i'm i'm going
busan it's like it's you know some other
state i'm going l.a with my boyfriend
let's just openly say about it first
when i heard about maybe
20 years ago or something they were
talking about going trip with the
boyfriend and then me myself i didn't
say a thing but
like that so yes it changed a lot
wow what incredible insight thank you so
much for that this is you know
i have so many questions for you i first
want to know because this is an
intergenerational show what do you think
older generations and younger
generations will learn about each other
watching
pachinko know i'm not good at the
learning but
personally
personally
you are so funny you're you're so funny
personally myself
i learned
of course through this show through the
script or through the novel
i learned personally so much
not only about the details of our
history about the human
story human being
that time
to
proceed to exist
to survive
that i learned
and
well
i was praying and then about the
generation
and
they
of course
i like this character because
she knew what will happen to them living
in foreign country as an immigrant
people but she didn't say a word she
just saying
very wisely
can can we do this and that way and
nothing's going to be changed we still a
minority something like that she always
said that but very
reserved and then very short word
and not
less is more less is more yes yes less
is more and
then that
that but we all have still have a
generation gap like me my experience you
know looking at you guys and then wow
they are very different but you know we
don't say a thing because like myself my
experience i didn't say anything that
girl was going
through with the boyfriend
i'm sure
yes we did and then
it has to be changed it has to be
changed you don't have to be
uh follow our generations you know what
they did or we could all make a mistake
and then you try not to make a mistake
like us
that's the
way we're supposed to look for the
future not the
past so i would wish
all the audience if they see our show we
don't have to
look back it already happened so they
can look forward to future and then
i'm so glad that i can honor their story
with this show because i learned myself
a lot about
that time so
well i'm so honored to like see you in
this show and and to even get the chance
to talk to you and for bringing these
stories to life you've made me love and
appreciate my own grandmother even
through your performance in minnetti and
and you're absolutely spectacular how
how do you feel about going back to the
oscars and how has the oscars changed
your career
winning an oscar
no
nothing changed i tran
but
rotten tomatoes very
friendly to me you are very kind
everyone who had an interview with from
rotten tomatoes during the campaign i
didn't know there was campaigning even
because i never been in oscar
in my life so i didn't know i
felt like i had too much interview with
my lack of english that was very severe
time and during the
i was shooting this pachinko at that
time actually
in bangkok
but
well it's
always it's been nice to be recognized
and
people appreciate your work but i'm
never pursuing a word well i didn't
expect a word while we were filming that
minari we didn't we were just
trying to help either
[Laughter]
and
no i was just feel like
how can i say it's a miracle or i kept
saying it's excellent who i got the
the one
where i got the award it's just to me
it's that accident
because
like i said we cannot
compete each other against each other
because we are all playing different
roles for the different movies so
i was just lucky to be
that moment i cut
that timing maybe
i'm just lucky
to
foreign
hello um minha minho minho actually i um
my friend chung wu's brother said that
you were the most handsome man at bon
bon ho middle
[Laughter]
so congratulations on pachinko my
favorite part of the show is the opening
credits scene where everybody is dancing
what was it like shooting that and who
was the best dancer on set
[Laughter]
i think if she didn't become an actress
she would have become a dancer
yeah i really enjoyed um
filming that opening sequence because i
got to dance for like two hours with my
favorite music so there was the
there was like almost like first and
then last time i really just
smiled and laughed and like enjoyed this
whole time
so yeah it was great it was amazing
um job i love that well it was such a
joy to watch you dance and it was a joy
to watch the both of you in this
american tv series what inspired you or
interest to both of you to be in this
show
story
uh so first of all i thought the
storyline was really strong um and in
that storyline there was uh the
different characters who in their own
ways survived in those harsh uh
conditions and the really difficult
times so i could really resonate with
their i guess resilience and i wanted to
definitely take part in the show
and then the opening school
and about the opening credit i actually
asked su hu the writer um
if we can be this happy because i'm not
that hanzo is not that kind of character
so i actually asked her if i can laugh
and if i can smile like that and i think
it was the only moment or the first
moment that hansu really
was having a lot of fun and he was all
happy so it was also a memorable
experience for me too
i love that because i was talking to
kogo nada and justin earlier and they
were saying the reason why the opening
was so happy is because the show is so
heavy and dark and then i also wanted
you to ask them because i think people
are
equally people are going to be so
excited to see you american audiences
are would you guys want to do more you
know american tv series like squid game
season 2 or other shows
yes of course i think we now live in an
era where we don't have any silos
between countries and um
like every country can share their
culture with one another
so it could be hollywood it could be you
know other countries if there's a good
story and a good project i definitely
want to be in on that project
nice the both of you share such a
beautiful romance on this film and i was
wondering did you do anything before
shooting scenes to bond or connect to
bring those really intimate scenes to
life
um
[Laughter]
[Music]
um
yeah so i thought it was really
important to make her feel comfortable
and myself come feel comfortable as well
and the way to do that i thought was to
share a lot of personal stories between
us so it doesn't have to be anything
related to pachinko we would just talk
amongst ourselves
about
you know like what kind of life i have
been leading get to know each other and
that's what i try to do in order to make
both of us feel comfortable
well we had a lot of conversations
talking about the scenes and about our
characters and our relationship between
and like we had to make a great
chemistry between two of us so yeah
we had a lot of conversation
and
um
for me like i really do appreciate minho
that he approached me in a very
comfortable way so i can be relaxed and
be just be myself and present on the set
so yeah that's what we do before the
filming
oh i love that um i also wanted to ask
you minha i read that you
talked to your grandmother about her
experience when developing your
character of sanja can you share maybe a
story or something that she said to you
that really stayed with you and helped
you develop the character
uh
well yeah my grandmother is 94 years old
so she really did uh leave in that era
so while i was like starting from the
childhood she told me a lot of uh
stories of herself like how she suffered
and um
how she overcame all these obstacles
that is very similar to the situation
that sanja faced it
so yeah i heard a lot of episodes of
herself but um so i while i was
listening to those episodes i kind of
wanted to figure out how would sanja
feel in this situation and that
situations but
there was one moment that she
had she told me that after i got this
role she told me that minha i'm really
happy you can do this role but i'm also
really sad that you have to
do this role even if it's a performance
so there was the one sentence that
oh my god yeah this is it this is just
whole whole story that sanjay has to
contain so
yeah i i think um i really want to share
this episode that um it was just all
whole big new sentence that really
attached me as an emotional ways wow
that hit me emotionally because
so intense right and it was so hard for
them and it's equally really hard for us
in different ways too
um so i i think it's beautiful that in a
way you were telling your grandma's
story i love that um minho
you haven't auditioned for a show in
like over a decade and i was talking to
sue hugh and she said she didn't have to
convince you to audition you really
wanted to do this so can you tell me
um
what dipping back into the audition
process was
foreign
[Music]
oh yes it was quite a long time since i
had an audition but you know audition is
an audition and i had to express myself
and get chosen um so i felt like i was
um back in my very early years of
starting this career and which i really
liked actually um and uh the the
difference was that before um when i was
auditioning for rose i felt kind of
pressured to really memorize the script
itself but this time um instead of
focusing too much on memorizing the
script i focus more on understanding and
analyzing the character and the vibe of
the character and the emotions of the
character
americans love games everything becomes
fun
so whenever i met anyone men mostly they
wanted to play the guessing game
which asian am i a classic
it's always chinese first
thankfully japanese usually comes in
second at least you only had two
countries to get through i'd be lucky if
korea made the top four
if i wasn't in the mood i'd just nod
when they said japan
it's not entirely inaccurate though is
it
no
not inaccurate i love the tension
between both of your characters so i was
hoping you could tell me how they view
each other and what direction justin and
kogonada gave you on set when you guys
were shooting scenes together we'll
start with um you anna
um i think that they have a love-hate
relationship in the beginning when we
meet um both of them together it's you
know she's not welcoming of him because
he's coming
from new york
and to seal the deal that everyone's
been wanting to work everyone has been
working on but has has been unsuccessful
with
and but slowly she gets to see the
person that he is and i think the fact
that um he's also considered an outsider
and he's also looked down
from
everyone because he's korean and she's
going through the same thing because
she's female i think that allows her to
kind of be open with him
i love it what about you jen
i think um okay so from i have my own
opinion as jinn but i think from
solomon's perspective because where he's
at when we first meet him in the office
he's quite i think of
ruthless
finance here at that time so i think for
him he sees naomi as an obstacle uh when
we first meet him he sees naomi as the
person who's
um
although there is this innate point of
connection because of our
marginalization and very different but
there is this sense of like both of us
have a chip on our shoulders
um
and so i think there's perhaps this
natural connection i also think that you
know there's a little bit of just like
their personalities might mesh because
they see themselves the ambition that we
both share is is palpable to both of us
and at the same time i think
when we first meet solomon we find him
in a lot more of a
blinders
mentality of trying to get this deal
done
so i don't think he does a lot to help
himself
you know ingratiate himself with naomi
at the beginning but then
as we go as we go along we see a little
bit more development of their
understanding of each other
i love when we first meet solomon that
scene that you do with the bosses and
you're just like and i want it all in
writing i was like yes this is going to
be a meme on instagram everyone's going
to be posting this it's going to be like
next time you have a meeting with your
right right yeah i hope everybody takes
that line and gets what they want
fight for what you're worth
um
how did you how did you get into
character as solomon and what about his
storyline and his connection to his
family did you connect to
um
solomon feels like
who i might have become if i didn't find
acting for myself if i didn't find that
that interest and passion and
performance
um
where my job literally is to empathize
and to learn about other people's
stories and to be emotionally
vulnerable
if i didn't have
this type of job i can imagine myself
falling into this world of finance or
consulting as a lot of my peers in
school
school did um
and obviously not to generalize unlike
the people that work in finance and
consulting but i just mean that there is
a
there are
parameters within different jobs that
prompt
people to
to behave differently or to investigate
different parts or not investigate
different parts of their own
lives and personalities and identities
and i think
had i not found acting
uh and been forced to constantly open
and and be
you know uh continually extend my
empathy
i can imagine i i imagine myself this is
me my alter ego if it was just slightly
more closed off a bit more mask
maxed up a bit more
um
manipulative might be too strong of a
word because i do think he's a good
person and i'm biased but i think he's a
good person at heart it's more just
i think he understands how to
get around and i think he understands
how to
um
get what he wants
in a way um and
that
aspect of his
personality although i think quite
different from who i am
it's not it's not that far off if i just
think about like what is what are his
motivations what drives him
and that very much to me
makes sense of a lot of his decisions
and his behavior and his choices
and then on top of that there's a whole
family aspect that you talked about
where like
him being the second generation him
being the first of his family's story to
have opportunity and access to wealth in
this way for the first time i think and
you know travel having studied in
america and worked in america
um
that is
so much of my own story as well i mean
different in a lot of specific details
but i came from
korea and hong kong when i was young and
immigrated to america new england mostly
and learned to
assimilate learn to fit in learn to try
and find myself within the context where
i i didn't obviously seem to fit in in
many ways
um and that adeptness at sort of
assimilating to wherever we are the code
switching so to speak that was
very accessible for me
yeah highly relatable too
yeah anna with naomi you know she's this
woman in japan in the 1980s who's risen
to the top of her company
how do you think she views the world and
did you write a backstory for her
you know so that you were informed about
how she got to where she is essentially
yeah yeah um i worked on it by myself
and with sue and with my mom i'm getting
information from my mom but uh
women during that time
the companies didn't want to hire women
who graduated four-year universities
because they were older and they were
expected to get married around 24 so
that meant they wouldn't have much time
at the office and so they would like
they wanted to hire people who went to
like what do you call the short
universities where you only study for
like two years um i mean at professional
schools perhaps right they they hired
more women from those kind of schools so
that
they would enter around 20 and then stay
at the company for four years and but
she has she's already 28 nine
when um we see her and so people are
very judgmental towards her
and um i spoke to my mom a lot because
she was working around the 80s as well
and she's been through very similar
things
and um
it's
you know it's really hard because i also
see a little bit of myself because
working in japan
especially i've had people make comments
on me because i'm a female working with
sue and you know really learning what
she wanted to
what is it share with the world was very
inspiring and i'm so happy that she
wanted to tell that side of the story as
well
just hearing both of you talk it's what
a cool project to be a part of where you
not only get to dive into like this new
character but also like your own family
and background and identity like it's
just it's so layered and deep and
beautiful in so many ways i can't wait
for the world to see it
jin you get to shoot a lot of scenes
with yeah john yoon
what was that like because she is such a
legend and did she bestow any wisdom
upon you
um in action she did i mean i i felt
like i was constantly in a master class
a very intimate master class whenever i
got to work with her um
there's such
i wonder if it comes with age and
experience or if
that's just who she's always been i mean
i've seen her work with kim kyung when
she first got started you know earlier
in the night uh 20th century what is it
like a woman on woman of fire i think
it's there's actually it's on youtube
but for free you can watch her earliest
films
when she's like in her 20s and
even then her performances i mean that's
what kicked her career off
but
even then for me i was like this is an
incredibly
gifted and skilled
and
captivating actor and then for me to
then fast forward you know what is it
however many decades i won't say for her
sake but you know it's to then have the
opportunity to
witness
and then even play with that that
wealth of history and knowledge and
experience for me was a joy
there's such
depth with her
simplicity and her stillness that
i'm interested in for myself as an actor
um
i was just trying to keep up you know
what i mean she was she was i mean she
was so lovely to work with and off
camera she's
a delight and i think exactly as she
comes off in her interviews um and
yeah i'm so grateful to have to have had
this this amazing opportunity to
cross paths with yj but also you know
get to know her as a person as well
[Music]
i
i love this show so much i was looking
up uh different korean words because i
was like i want to learn korean and what
i thought was so beautiful is that one
of the greetings in korean really is a
question that means are you at peace
and i thought wow that's so cool
so i just wanted to say hi and are you
at peace knowing that you're bringing
this
highly anticipated show
to a major streamer i don't know i mean
i don't know yet if it feels it's still
a little bit surreal like a part of me
someone's i'm waiting for someone to say
wait we're not done yet um it's been
such a long journey that to think it's
actually over the first season is um
i'm struggling accepting it
okay well it's common and i'm so excited
for the world to see and also your
narrow your nail color is stunning oh
thank you
sick i want to first ask you and i know
you've been asked this before but i
think it's an important question to ask
you know the book is in english but the
show is in japanese korean and english
why was it important to tell this story
on screen through those native languages
you know i think
it was so important that whatever
language the character spoke had to be
the language that we heard i mean not
only is it that you want the best actors
for the role right why would you want to
hamper an actor with a language he or
she is not comfortable with but most
importantly i think the world really
needs to hear people speak
right
and there's no way we're going to be
able to understand especially that
divide between how the struggle between
switching from korean to japanese unless
you told the language for example if it
was on english you wouldn't understand
when a character code shifted to another
language
so that just felt really crucial
you know what was interesting when i was
there was a scene in episode one where
there's a bunch of men talking in the
pachinko parlor and i just thought
this is so i'm so connected to these
people because if i was actually in the
room i wouldn't be understanding what
they're saying and so i felt i just
wanted you to know as someone watching i
felt so connected and almost like i got
an inside look you know at this world
that i wouldn't otherwise thank you so
much yeah i really i truly felt that um
so i hope you're so proud of yourself i
i watched an interview you did last week
where you said
you know you knew how challenging and
and epic this is and
how did it challenge you
oh in so many ways um
i mean just digging into all that
history right like having to figure out
like what life was like in 1915 what
life was like in 1923 1931
and then
what that happened by doing that i
uncovered so much in my own family's
history right like wait a minute my
grandparents went through that you know
my parents went through that
and
it was that was a complicated emotion
those were complicated emotions that dug
up in that process the translation of
these scripts not just into you know
japanese and korean but also into all
these dialects within japanese and
korean
that was that was a big headache um
and
you know shooting it was a very
ambitious shoot it was
it was a big shoot and just
the bar was so high right and
all of us saying
that's not good enough yet we can do
better that's not good enough we can do
better until we got to that place where
we're like yes we got it
you definitely got it uh i was watching
another interview you did where you said
you used the godfather as a reference
and i was like hmm let's let's ask sue
you know what does she love about the
godfather and how did that influence the
intergenerational story and the family
story in pachinko yeah so i watched the
godfather when i was very young at 12
years old and i really do credit the
godfather with being the spark of like
wait a minute
people make movies like people tell
stories like that what is that and for
me it's very much the inciting action of
like this is what i want to do but when
i think about godfather 2 especially you
know
it's very hard to cross cut periods it's
very hard to cross-cut past and present
and make it feel like one conversation
and i think what that movie in the
second one movie does especially because
michael goes back to his homeland
and
like ah what if we did that with
pachinko right you know
what if we told that structure and
i think i think it was the right
decision
you told it seamlessly too because you
know as someone that watches a lot of
stuff there's stuff that takes place
over different time periods and i'm the
worst i can never follow it
and and that never happened when i was
watching pachinko um oh good yeah really
really awesome so exciting to see minho
in this yeah you know he's massive and i
read that he hadn't done an audition in
a decade so how did you convince him to
audition for this and tell me about the
casting process we didn't have to
convince him he wanted it bad enough you
know and so
i think
he was just
he worked so hard you know and he really
wanted to just tap into a different
facet of his acting and i really think
when people see pachinko and they see
what he brings to hanzo i think no one
will see minho the same way i'm so
excited we're able to see him do you
when people are done watching this
they're going to be wondering you know
is the second season coming what stories
do you want to tell you know if there is
a season two well i mean the show is
meant to be ongoing so you know fingers
crossed
but it's just when i think about season
one
i love these characters so much right
you you you want to see what happens to
them and i hope you get that opportunity
nice and going back to casting for a
second how did you land on the three
different actresses for sinja
yeah because that's that's hard right to
like make one person have three people
be one person we decided not to force it
meaning let's not cast trying to make
them look alike right let's not cast
trying to and also let's not
make their performances mimic or match
one another when you have actors of that
strength
what you're looking for is someone who
can embody the soul of this character
and once we had that then i knew they
were going to be fine
[Music]
and people like us we don't need to walk
in our family's shadows
hello hi jason and croco nada what a
pleasure watching the show
i was like this show is so epic in scope
and yet intimate in tone and the entire
time i was watching i was like how did
they do that like they're just so good
at what they do but uh so
congratulations my first question is
about the opening credits scene the cast
dancing in the pachinko parlor because i
think we live in a world where everyone
just skips the opening credits and i
didn't skip once every single episode i
was so excited how long did that take to
choreograph and what all went into that
do you have insight on that you were
there on that yeah uh
so
okay so
basically
the show is very emotional
and it's it's a very it can be heavy
time so like i think it's the thought
processes have something that
starts with some levity
um you know so like
i think there's a tempting thing an
obvious choice for a show like this to
do some like you know strings orchestral
sort of sweeping music with like
landscapes and stuff but i thought this
was a much more clever way of of getting
into it where where it starts off on
it's just a you know a rocket shift of
joy first before we get into all the the
difficult things we tackle
i love that i love that sentiment
coconut what was it like shooting that
were you there that day um i don't think
i was there i think i was shooting
another scene uh but i think or but
maybe not because i think my dp did
anton shoot a little bit and florian
yeah so they were it was like a group
effort yeah yeah
it was a group effort and i think a lot
of it was just freestyled i think that
like they just let them
obviously they they shot it on on uh k
set uh at the the pachinko parlor but um
they just let them
kind of free form yeah yeah and let them
dance put it together yeah
[Laughter]
can't wait for the world to see it but
justin like you said this show has a lot
of heavier themes and i was thinking
about how this is the first time that
both of you are directing a television
series which i thought is really
interesting so i'd love to hear a little
bit about that but what did the both of
you learn about you know korean identity
and korean history while making this
show
yeah i mean you know i because of my own
family history which uh intersects this
story um i was familiar but it really
was about fleshing out that history and
really feeling it in the context of
uh you know because if you're a kid and
as you're growing up
it still feels abstract and you're still
trying to imagine
the stories you're hearing but suddenly
kind of being a part of it and being in
within certain kinds of geography and
location and feeling the costumes and um
you know it was really about learning
that the texture of the history if that
makes any sense you know that for me
that's what i walked away from is like
really feeling it under you know in my
body almost
i love that i love that feeling the
costumes line that's that's incredible
justin what about you you know what did
you take away from this and learn about
korean identity
uh you know on a just a human level that
that that
you know we're just
we're just a lot so much more like than
different as a human as a human race
you know and i think uh great
storytelling
is in its specificity you know
you know un sort of like exposes how
much
more we're alike
um when i you know i i love to watch
film and whether it's an iranian story
or
or you know uh story from sweden you
know you you just you watch these films
and you walk in their shoes for however
long your the the film or the television
show is
and there's so much to to relate with it
that for this show
i was very much focused on on the the
human elements um a lot of times that
that
that we all can relate to
yeah well that really shines through and
and the first thing i thought of was how
when you were saying that like the
different stories is when i watched
minari you know ya jung yoon made me
love my own grandmother so much and it
is funny how we can see each other in
other stories reflected and we are so
much more alike than we are different
what was it like directing oscar winner
yajno
she's hilarious it seems yeah yeah well
i i did this one scene with all these
rain towers and and i i made her and it
was in the dead of winter and she was pr
she was pretty mad at me dude
really because i made her stand in the
rain and in the water too long and i got
a call and and i just had to get on my
knees and beg for forgiveness
yeah i mean she she's uh such a legend
even before the you know she was sort of
introduced to the western world you know
she's been this legend in korea and so
it's a it's daunting but also
you know she's so mesmerizing i mean i
got to shoot like an earthquake scene
and big scenes and her just sitting at a
table talking
was the maybe
sometimes my the most compelling thing i
was doing as an actor just putting that
camera on her face and letting her play
all these different notes it was really
sort of as a director was a real honor
to kind of see this legend play these
notes on her face and in her eyes it you
know i i was really like
stunned by her um abilities as an actor
100
so beautifully said she is so absorbing
and and she just brings you in you know
and another thing that brought me in
while watching this show is i really
love elements and i love the element of
water and i wanted to ask about the view
about shooting in and around water and
specifically that scene of soonja diving
how you know how did you shoot that and
tell me about using water as an element
to tell this story
yeah well you know korea is the
peninsula and japan is an island so it
is a part of our landscape you know it's
it's our geography um
so and it was so well water was so
integral to to the script and um so we
knew that that was just going to be a
part of the element one of the elemental
parts of the story the diving was a
combination of really be on a coast and
then obviously using a tank as well and
our actor she was such a good swimmer
and a good sport about everything uh so
that that was yeah it took a you know a
full day to kind of do some uh
underwater scenes with her um and she
was brilliant um
yeah and then just you know dealing with
the the travel uh on the boat and all of
that was uh yeah it was just a big part
of our our production absolutely
i love that water scene of um the
laundry because you you shot that so
differently and you go with the three
the three oh yeah yeah yeah upstream and
and i thought that was incredible yeah
yeah no no i think water is really
important you know even um
when we shot you know uh
at the end of episode four with solomon
and and older sanja you know
um
i wanted to bring back in the water so i
had it rain you know in the script it
would they didn't have rain
but i felt like if it was raining at the
same time for both of them connects them
in an emotional way and also that she's
going to step into i also think it's
also just
i love i love the visual of like you're
you're stepping into water but it's also
like raining from the heavens
um there's something i think very
spiritual about about water right yeah
how long can you guys hold your breath
under water
that was wow i mean everything you guys
are saying it's like an orchestra it's
like a symphony coming out of your mouth
it's like you guys were trained to do
this forever
i also want to ask you aside from
shooting with water food right food can
make us feel really seen i'm dominican i
remember seeing john m chu shoot food
and in the heights and i was like oh my
god i got chills i was like i've never
seen this dominican meal in in a show
like this people are going to be so
hungry watching this
so beautiful tell me about crafting why
was it so important to get those shots
and and crafting the food as a character
in this show
it's it's an extension of of it's
symbolic right you know um
and it's it's history and it's it's just
just uh we can all relate with our our
ethnic food right but um i don't know
like
even in uh episode four when she's
the rice is so expensive the white rice
that
that it's a such a treat and it's a
mother's heart you know it's a mother's
heart so it's the last gesture and
and uh you know she could do for a
departing daughter and and i think
there's just so much love in the way you
can shoot things like that and and we
all
we all know what it feels like when when
a mother cooks it even if it doesn't
taste good you know a beautiful meal for
you because it's all heart
yeah i mean you when you said which you
should really be doing the interview
because you or you should be the
interviewee because um
you said it was epic and scope intimate
in tone i was like why can't i say that
yeah i'm gonna steal that from you but
the you know um it's such a big story
but when
food immediately grounds you and makes
it so
everyday and intimate and we all have
that relationship with food that no
matter how big the world events are when
you're sitting at a table and eating
food it becomes this sort of intimate
thing that is universal we all
understand it and that daily food is the
thing that we will recall and it becomes
emotional
and whether you see it in the heights
where you know we like when i see a bowl
rice kimchi this you know that set up
you know it's like oh i'm back at my
house and and so there's something
really intimate about food that
was a big part of this show i think
you